why we explore
mars the mysteries of the red planet the
history of water the possibilities
of life you learn something and then you
design the next mission based on what
you learn
has allowed us to literally go back in
time on mars
the first picture will cover an area of
176 miles
mariner 4 began transmitting back images
the first
photograph that a human being has ever
seen
from the surface of another planet on
august 20th
1975 the first viking spaceship was
launched
you were seeing something that no other
human has
ever seen before former siege and
mountains
huge canyons
[Applause]
that sense of wonderment and achievement
and always working towards your goal
we can do and we will do
and liftoff
mars is unavoidably special we've landed
and we've scooped
we've roved we've orbited together
we did it but the attitude was together
we can do it
the future is what you make out of it
you can make it real
and here we are with mars perseverance
51 years later getting ready to do the
first
ever mars return mission eventually we
can bring those samples
back to earth and determine for the very
first time
did life exist on mars
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the nasa kennedy space center
for the mars 2020 mission tech and
humans to mars briefing
i'm tammy long of nasa communications
and this afternoon we are going to
unpack some
truly spectacular technology
on board the mars perseverance rover we
encourage you to follow the mission
at nasa persevere and we would love to
have your questions for the panel
please use the hashtag countdown to mars
it is my distinct privilege and honor to
introduce this amazing panel
we begin at nasa headquarters in
washington dc
with jim watson the director of nasa's
mars
exploration program live with us in
studio
is dr jeffrey shihai chief engineer
of nasa's space technology mission
directorate
then we're blasting west and going to
the jet propulsion laboratory in
pasadena california
for mimi ong the project manager of the
mars
ingenuity helicopter then we're
launching back to the east coast
to cambridge massachusetts to michael
hecht he's the principal
investigator for moxie and the associate
director
for the mit haystack observatory and
then of course we're coming back south
to the johnson space center in houston
texas for amy ross
who's a planetary spacesuit engineer i
want that on my business card
and finishing off with michelle rucker
she leads a cross-agency team
for architecture and operational
concepts
for the first human mission to mars
wow what a panel so let's get it kicked
off with jim at nasa headquarters who's
going to give us a quick mars 2020
overview
and tell us where it's leading us hello
jim
thank you tammy boy i just have to
remark those videos that you
teed up this whole event with you they
never get old
i have a chart here that i brought along
that sort of summarizes some of our more
recent history
and what i wanted to do and address this
afternoon with everybody is explain a
little bit
how we were able to accomplish so much
so if you look at the
past 20 years nasa has been following a
very
uh focused and strategic
plan to explore mars and it's been
guided by setting a strategy of what we
call
follow the water and we did that because
we know that water is key
for life here on earth it's also key to
how
how the climate behaves it's also key to
understanding how the surface of a
planet
forms so starting back at the uh
around 2000 actually the late 1990s we
started with a series of orbiters
and these orbiters we sent to mars to do
remote sensing to capture
imagery so we could create the maps of
what the surface looks like
what the geology looks like to
characterize it get a sense for the
mineralogy that's on the surface
and start to form our understanding of
how that planet may have formed
and how that surface has evolved over
time but we knew to do the real
serious work we had to get down to the
surface so we started in 1996 we sent a
very small rover
you'd hardly recognize it today when you
compared it with the perseverance rover
it's a tiny little thing but a little
bit bigger than the shoebox
and that we landed on mars and that's
how we first learned
how to survive on the surface of mars
and how to
operate on the surface of mars so that
we could do work
we could do exploration work we learned
a lot from that
and so we established a new program
that had the spirit and opportunity
rovers we sent those two together
as a pair and very very successful
program there
so spirit and opportunity together
established that mars truly was
habitable
that it had abundant water on the
surface in many forms
in the forms of large lakes small lakes
flowing rivers
even hot springs so with that knowledge
in hand and the experience that we
gained operating these
spirit and opportunity rovers we went
and developed our what has been our
flagship to date and that's the
curiosity rover
almost a metric ton in weight and
outfitted with a lot of very very
precise instrumentation
including a mass spectrometer to help
tell us what the
molecular structure was of of the
samples that we were able to probe
we've been exploring mars since 2011
and from that success and from the data
that's returned from that we have
commissioned
the perseverance rover on the mars 2020
project and we're going to
launch that on thursday and that rover
is following in the footsteps of
that legacy of rovers so we'd try
something
first we'd learn from it we'd evolve new
technologies
apply them and feed forward into the
next rover we'd learn some more
feed them forward into the next rover
and perseverance is
no exception perseverance is loaded with
new technology
new operational techniques that we're
going to experiment so that we can
explore mars in even greater detail
and in fact we're setting up the next
great campaign
at mars mars sample return in the sense
that perseverance
is going to take samples and cache them
and they'll be retrieved by future
missions and bring them home to be
studied in laboratories here on earth
so you might ask well perseverance
looking at new technologies that'll
enable future exploration what possibly
do we have yet to learn well we still
have a lot
okay we still can't land exactly where
we want to be
the error circle for perseverance is on
the order of 10 kilometers
when we send humans to mars and when we
pursue
sample return we need to land even
closer
to where we want to be than that so we
hope to improve that yet another order
of magnitude and so there's technologies
that we're going to use in the
perseverance landing
we're going to experiment with how we
can get even closer
we've improved our algorithms for how we
deploy our parachutes
and we've added a new sensor that can
view the terrain
on the final descent and from that we
can determine if we're flying towards
hazard
and take corrective action we also when
we explore mars in the future we want to
be able to live off the land in some
respects we don't want to have to carry
everything that we need
and so it's going to be very important
for future explorers
both robotic and human to be able to get
some substance from the planet so we
have an experiment on board a technology
demonstration you'll hear about today
called moxie and it's going to extract
oxygen from the atmosphere
we also have an instrument on mars 2020
as a ground penetrating radar and we're
going to start to probe the upper 10
meters or so of the surface of mars
understand the soil structure and the
rock structure and start to do the
necessary
civil engineering then we will have to
know
whether that soil can support the larger
landers
that humans will take in the future to
go to mars we also need to forecast the
weather better
okay if you recall uh not too long ago
we lost the opportunity rover
and we lost it because there was a
planet enveloping dust storm
that obscured the sunlight that can no
longer charge its battery
when we have human explorers on mars we
want to be able to forecast these
before they happen so we can take
precautions for the safety of the crew
and lastly
we need to be able to come home from our
sample return
the first round trip to another planet
that will be the first time using
robotic systems
that we land get samples from another
mission get the treasure that we're
that we find in exploring and launch
them back into mars orbit
and then ultimately bring them home to
earth we want to run those trap lines if
you will with robotic systems
before we develop the larger and more
expensive and more capable human systems
so you're going to hear about some of
these technologies this afternoon
they're very exciting and they all
contribute to the future of exploration
thank you jim for setting up our mission
2020 for the overview
and now we would like to ask jeff to
talk about some of the new technologies
that are being featured in the mars 2020
mission
well the agency understands that
technology drives exploration
and in the space technology mission
director we're
super excited to have some technologies
on board the mars 2020 mission and the
perseverance rover
jim laid out the the uh the plan for
this mission and
and uh highlighted some of these
technologies that are being included on
the
on the mission and and and will go to
the surface with the rover
this mission will contribute to enabling
human exploration by
giving us technology that can help us
land more precisely and more hazardous
locations
a lot of the interesting places you want
to explore on mars are also hazardous
places to land your spacecraft and so
having precise landing technology is
really important it'll
provide technologies that will allow us
to live off the land
to utilize resources that we find on
mars
to make commodities that we need to do
exploration missions and
even as jim mentioned to forecast the
weather
we've worked with a variety of partners
uh science mission directorate human
exploration and operations mission
directorate
several of the nasa field centers even
the spanish
national research council on these
technologies
and there are four particular items that
i'd like to highlight for you today
two of these will be utilized during the
entry descent and landing
phase of the mission those seven minutes
of terror when the
spacecraft first enters the atmosphere
and then is
descending all the way to the surface
and then the other two technologies will
be utilized when
we reach the surface during the surface
operations of the rover
the first of the technologies i want to
highlight is called
medley ii that stands for mars
entry descent and landing
instrumentation
and it's the second round for this we
have an image that i'd like to show
that shows the spacecraft you can see
there the heat shield on the bottom
and the back what they call the back
shell on the top and
embedded in the heat shield and the back
shell are
a number of instruments there's
thermocouples there's heat flux sensors
and there's pressure transducers and
they collect data
at the various locations on the heat
shield during the descent
and the back shell during the descent
through the atmosphere
on those last seven minutes of flight
when we
take measurements of this nature we
answer a lot of questions and when we
look at the data we
realize that we have new questions and
so medley 2
builds on the heritage of the 2012
landing of curiosity where we had
similar types of in
instrumentation not in all the same
locations
on that light and we learned a lot and
we raised some new questions and some of
those questions we're going to answer
on this flight the way we use the data
is to validate models
that that we use when we develop new
spacecraft that we want to land on mars
jim showed the progression of rovers
from small little rovers to
things like perseverance that the size
maybe of a small suv
well for human exploration we're going
to have to land
something the size of a two-story
condominium on mars something that
weighs
20 tons or more not just a ton
and so i mean it's amazing to be able to
land a ton
on mars but eventually we're gonna have
to land 20 tons on mars and so
um as we design the new landing systems
and the
spacecraft we have on mars it's
important to be able to mop
that landing
portion of the of the mission and make
sure that we can land those systems
safely so the data we get from medley ii
will be able to provide that validation
for entry descent and landing models
another technology that i want to
highlight
is called terrain relative navigation
it allows to pinpoint the landing zone
on mars
and this is a technology that will allow
us to land more accurately
in the locations we want and in more
hazardous locations
you know in apollo 11 neil armstrong
looked out the window and said
i don't really like where we're headed
here or something very close to that
and and so he took over control from the
autumn
mated guidance system of the lunar
lander
and guided it past the crater guided it
past some large boulders so that he
could land safely at the
sea of tranquility well we don't have
neil armstrong or any other astronaut on
board
the perseverance landing but we do have
terrain relative navigation
and it provides the two very important
things
one is better knowledge of where is
perseverance over the
surface of the of the landing zone and
then the ability to
divert if we see that we're headed
toward
an unfavorable landing area just like
neil armstrong did on apollo 11.
it has a lander vision system that
compares images
and actually we have an animation of
this that we can show
it compares images of the landing site
that
that's that are being taken as the
spacecraft descends through the
atmosphere with maps that have been
prepared from orbital missions and
and so it can get some information on
where it is
over the surface of mars then that
information is fed into a
safe target selection system that
calculates where the rover is going to
touch down
and then compares images with different
maps
that have identified in the maps
the safe landing zones and also
especially bad landing zones and so
if it sees that perseverance is headed
toward a bad site
it can institute a divert the
landing system thrusters will fire and
move the spacecraft
toward a more safe landing site this is
uh the kind of technology that we'll
need as jim mentioned to
land several assets in close proximity
to each other in order to enable human
exploration
at some future day so i've talked about
two
technologies that will be used during
the entry descent and landing portion of
the mission
during operations on the surface there
are two additional key technologies that
i want to highlight
the first of these is called meta
m-e-d-a
it stands for mars environmental
dynamics analyzer
it's a contribution from the spanish
national research council
with funding from nasa particularly the
space technology mission directorate
it's a collection of sensors that are
designed to detect the
amount and the size of dust particles in
the atmosphere on mars
as well as make a bunch of weather
measurements kind of similar to what you
might make with your
uh weather system in the backyard it'll
it'll
measure the temperature both the air
temperature and the ground temperature
it'll measure the humidity it'll measure
the atmospheric pressure
it'll measure the solar radiation and
and then they'll accumulate all that
data and it'll uh
we'll be able to determine how the
environment
the weather environment the environment
that we find on mars
affects the performance of systems
on perseverance and then ultimately when
we land astronauts on mars
and one of them turns to another and
says hey what's the weather like today
they'll be able to have a weather
forecast of what the weather's like on
expect now i didn't leave it for last
um i left it for last because my
principal investigator will be talking
about it in just a little bit
and so i don't want to steal too much of
his thunder but i'll just mention it
jim watson mentioned it also it's called
moxie
the name of it uh kind of invokes a
certain kind of attitude that i think is
appropriate
for this kind of ambitious mission it's
the first
ever in situ resource utilization
experiment on another planet it's going
to suck in the atmosphere of mars
and turn it into oxygen i saved it for
last because mike will talk about it and
and
i'm sure he's eager to tell you about it
so i won't say any more about moxie but
i'll just close by saying that space
technology
mission directorate is excited to be
part of this fabulous mission
i want to thank jim and his colleagues
at science mission director
for letting our technologies ride along
with them and thank you all for letting
me describe them to you
thank you jim for a non-technical mere
mortal like myself
it is absolutely mind-blowing the
technology we're sending on the mars
perseverance rover and on that note
we're going to the jet propulsion
laboratory to speak with mimi
who's going to take us to an
introduction
for the mars ingenuity helicopter
another
extraordinary experiment mimi
thank you tammy hi so this is
full-scale model of the mars helicopter
ingenuity
so the mars helicopter technology
demonstration
on mars 2020 will attempt the very first
rotograph flight at mars in fact we as
human beings have never flown a
rotograph
outside of our own earth's atmosphere so
this will actually be a very much
a wright brothers moment except on
another planet
well flying a rotograph at mars is very
difficult
um first and foremost the atmosphere
there is very thin
about one percent compared to the
earth's atmospheric density
here and so to build a vehicle that can
fly at mars it has to be very light and
be able to spin
very fast so going on to the model here
of our solution okay there is a
solar panel that will garner solar
energy
from the sun there is an antenna for
wireless communication
it has a rotor system ingenuity has a
1.2 meter diameter rotor system
two pairs of counter rotating blades
they'll spin
about 2 400 revolutions per minute
and under here is a fuselage that
contains a battery that will store the
energy
gathered by the solar cells and it's
surrounded by custom
lightweight circuit boards that will
perform onboard autonomous
flight and landing on boards management
of the
thermal the temperature based on the
temperature sensors
it will manage the onboard energy it
will perform the telecommunication
and the fuse at large is also equipped
with on-board sensors
cameras accelerometer gyros inclinometer
and an altimeter uh to for the vehicle
uh to use on with an onboard estimation
of the state
for the onboard autonomous flight and
then the vehicle has the landing gear
the entire vehicle that you see here
weighs in
just under 1.8 kilogram it's just about
four pounds
and that's been the very beginning
fundamental challenge of building
a rotorcraft that can fly at mars
so there is a significant team behind
making this happen
i'm very happy to be here on behalf of
the team
and this 1.8 kilogram challenge
you know is tackled by this large team
across from jpl
multiple sensors at multiple centers
across nasa
and critical industrial partners and we
worked very tightly together rolled up
our sleeps
we had to set aside our traditional
technical boundaries
uh that we have from our individual
disciplines of engineering to really
come
forward with this tight-knit solution to
meet this
ultimate 1.8 kilogram limit and we are
very happy
it weighed in just a hair under 1.8
kilogram
so since then the mars helicopter
ingenuity has been tested in mars-like
uh environments and we have flown it in
mars like atmospheric density here at
jpl the space simulator
chamber and so with the tests all tests
possible done at mars
the next thing to do is to test the moss
ingenuity
in the real environment that is being
designed and
done testing for on earth the next
destination
launch in space and at mars so at this
very moment
helicopter ingenuity is accommodated on
perseverance rover
waiting for launch and if we could play
the video please
after perseverance rover lands and
deploys a helicopter to the surface of
mars
we have 30 martian days planned to
perform
our flight experiments these will be the
very first
rotograph test flight on another planet
so very exciting days ahead for our team
um and in fact this is truly the highest
high reward phase of our project we've
tested everything we can on earth
and from launch forward every event we
have
will be the very first remotely
operated activities in space
during cruise and all the way to the
surface and so
that's a very high risk but very high
reward
because all our mathematical algorithms
the tests that we have done
and the actual hands-on experience and
learning
from operating this very first aerial
vehicle in space
they will feed directly into future
generations of
uh rotocrafts of much more sophisticated
series
as jim and jeff describe just as the
little sojourner
rover was a tech demo that showed how a
rover could work and followed by
generations of much more sophisticated
generations of rovers this mars
helicopter ingenuity
could lead to the opening up a whole new
way to explore
uh space exploration missions to the
aerial dimension
so we're very excited about it and thank
you for
having uh our team i'm glad to be here
to represent our team and i'm very glad
to be here
tammy back to you
thank you mimi you can be sure that
we've all got our fingers crossed that
ingenuity is going to fly what an
amazing experiment
and so now we're going to fly across the
states from jpl
to cambridge massachusetts where michael
hecht
is going to explain what the moxie is
what it does
and why it's so important hello michael
hello tammy thank you very much so
thanks all of you who are listening
and a shout out to the media in
particular we couldn't do this without
you
somewhere out there i'm at home
obviously many of you are at home
and somewhere out there maybe among the
younger folks uh
there's someone who will someday go to
mars okay
um 15 20 25 years it's going to happen
and when you go you know think about it
you'll need things you'll need a place
to live you'll need
a way to breathe you need a way to get
around and you'll need a way to get home
and the first leg of getting home is
getting on a rocket
and being lifted from the ground to
orbit so
all those things it turns out the single
heaviest thing you'll need
a great big tank of liquid oxygen
so that the rocket can breathe not so
you can breathe you need to breathe but
you don't breathe very much compared to
a rocket
okay a rocket breathes a lot and what do
i mean by that
anything that burns fuel breathes
whether it's you
a fire you know if you shut off the air
the fire goes out
a jet plane or a rocket but when you go
to space
or to mars you need to bring that
oxygen and it weighs way way more than
the fuel it's burning
so wouldn't it be great if we could make
that oxygen
on mars instead of having to bring it
all away with us
so let me get the model here
this is moxie okay this is a solid model
uh 3d model of moxie and this
indeed does what i just described it
makes oxygen
on mars out of resources it finds there
well what resources am i talking about
now mimi already mentioned how thin the
air is at mars
there's not a lot of it but what's there
is almost entirely
co2 so can we turn co2 into oxygen
well trees do it every day okay and we
wouldn't be able to breathe if it wasn't
for the flora and fauna of this planet
that turned
co2 into oxygen so we want to bring a
little tree to mars
as a demonstration this is in fact a
little tree
it puts out about as much oxygen from
co2 as a small tree does
how does it do okay um first thing you
have to do is collect all of that
thin air of it and compress it
we have of course a compressor this was
developed by
a company in colorado air squared
to work particularly on mars in that
special
thin air harsh environment once it's
collected it feeds it to
this red device this is called a solid
oxide electrolysis system
or a sox being from boston i insisted on
a red sox for the model
um and that's where the magic happens
so why is it we even know how to build
this how to build
something that will turn co2 into oxygen
we don't
often need to make oxygen on earth we
have all we
need well it's because the process that
goes the other way is called a fuel cell
when you start with with with a fuel
and oxygen and turn it into a stable gas
and get out electricity
we call it a fuel cell in this case
we're going to go the other way
so what way are we going well we start
with co2
which is carbon dioxide obviously carbon
dioxide has
oxide has oxygen in it what we want to
do is borrow
one of those oxygen atoms from the co2
why just one well because that way what
comes out
is co a gas and oxygen a gas and gases
are easy
you breathe them in they go out you have
no mess to clean up
so what comes out of out of moxie in
this case out of the soxy
is uh the socks is co2
that's unused and mixed with co that is
used
and then a stream of totally pure oxygen
that goes into a sensor system which
measures it and tells us what's going on
back on earth
and that's basically how it works i'd be
happy to answer more
technical questions in the discussion
later
thank you very much
thank you michael moxie what an
incredible
little machine the little engine machine
i tell you
oxygen yes well now we're going to go
from cambridge massachusetts down to
johnson space center
in houston texas for amy ross
our planetary spacesuit engineer
hello amy hi tammy
yeah i was so excited when mark freeze
and trevor graff the project lead for
the
sherlock instrument calibration target
approached me and offered us the
opportunity to put spacesuit materials
on the calibration target
i'll tell you why as a planetary
spacesuit engineer
i have two primary jobs the first is to
keep the astronauts alive
the second is to give them a good tool
to do the work they need to do in
and then the mars missions that will
eventually send humans on
are going to be more challenging than
any we've tried before
humans will be on the surface up to 500
days
and they will be doing routine evas
throughout that time
and so when i send somebody to mars in
my spacesuit i want to make sure
that they stay alive that whole time i
need a durable reliable spacesuit
to do that i need to understand how my
materials of the spacesuit
hold up over that duration of use so if
we can show my first slide
you can see the perseverance rover up in
the upper right hand corner
and then the calibration target is
located on the sherlock
instrument and the calibration target is
shown on the lower right
and so there are round circles above and
then
the colors with the round circle and
then the squares below it
are my spacesuit materials a calibration
target is basically how you can
check your focus on a camera as an
example um
it gives you a chance to make sure that
your instrument is still working
properly
and so in addition to those test
articles
we have my spacesuit materials these
space materials are key to the
spacesuits function
polycarbonate vectran orthofabric teflon
and then we're doing an experimental
fabric
that's one that we haven't used before
called a coated teflon
so if you can come back and look at the
materials here i have examples of those
with me this is a spacesuit helmet this
material here is polycarbonate
the spacesuit glove the material on the
palm is vectran
then the ortho fabric is a material
that's the white that you see on most of
the rest of the outside of the suit
and then the teflon is the gauntlet in
the back of the hand of the glove
and then we have a coated teflon that's
going to be a dust mitigating material
we want to do tests on in the mars
atmosphere
so we can understand how our materials
hold up or don't
in that environment and then we're doing
tests on the ground
that give us a data to compare to that
on mars data
so that we can have confidence when we
design a spacesuit that we are designing
the spacesuit
to last for the entire duration of
missions and keep our astronauts alive
this is a something my mentor and i had
talked about for
years he tried to do it had to retire
after 50 years of spacesuit experience
without getting this done
so this is a major career goal for me to
have what i think
is to the best of my knowledge as the
first human space flight hardware to go
to mars
and then that feeds my next career goal
which is sending a spacesuit to mars so
our future astronauts can use it there
so i'm really glad to be here too i'm
super excited to be included in the
perseverance mission
and i want to thank my colleague
christine davis who did most of the work
to get this
realized and on the vehicle
thank you amy extraordinary technology
with those fabrics i can't wait to see
how they do on mars and sitting next to
amy in the studio at johnson space
center we're joined by michelle rucker
she oversees a cross-agency team looking
at
architecture and operational concepts
for the first
human mission to mars so michelle tell
us about what the future is going to
look like
thanks tim tammy so we know more about
mars today than we knew about the moon
when apollo 11 touched down
and the reason we know so much about
mars is thanks to all of the robotic
science missions that jim mentioned
earlier
those those robotic missions have done
important science on mars
they've taught us about the environment
on mars and that is helping us to design
the equipment that
the humans will need to be able to live
and work on mars someday
the science is very important for
helping us to design
our systems but the technology
demonstration opportunities that these
missions give us
is also important so jeff and and
michael have talked about some of the
technology
those technologies will help us make the
missions
that that we're going to send humans on
much safer
so for example moxie that offers the
promise that we'll never run out of
oxygen on mars
i know all eyes are on mars this month
this happens to be a big
big month with three missions uh
international emissions going to
to mars but don't forget we're also
going back to the moon
some of the technologies that will be
demonstrated on perseverance will also
have applicability to the moon so the
terrain
relative navigation system that jeff
talked about
that could just as easily make landings
on the moon
safer than they were back in the apollo
days
as an engineer i have been i have to
admit i've been smitten with the
the mars helicopter ever since i first
saw test footage of it about two years
ago
um my colleagues and i have been like
kids in a candy store trying to think of
the different ways we could use that
technology for a human mars mission
i think we have an image we can show the
artists have been going a little bit
crazy uh it's hard to see there but uh
this
this is just an artist's uh depiction of
what it might look like
having a human mission on mars you see a
couple of astronauts there
uh they've got a pressurized rover in
the background that helicopter
we have just all kinds of ideas for how
to use that for a human mars mission
um i know poor mimi is trying to get
ready for a launch and i've been
pestering her with questions
uh for example can we use that
helicopter as an
aerial communications relay in case an
astronaut loses
line-of-sight communication back to
their rover say they go behind a hill or
something and don't
and they lose their communications could
we use that helicopter to get an
aerial view of the first human lander
our landers as jeff mentioned will be
perhaps 20 times
bigger than than the robotic landers we
expect those big powerful descent
engines to kick up a lot of dust during
landing
if you had a camera up on a helicopter
with an aerial point of view you might
get a much better
image of the first uh human mars mission
landing so
we're super excited um that
and i apologize to mimi for pestering
you with questions
those questions can wait till next week
the human missions will have their day
today though is about the robotic
science missions and the technology
demonstrations
for my colleagues at jpl just know that
those of us
on the the human exploration side of the
family will all be getting up early next
thursday
i will be cheering you on as you help
lay the groundwork for for us to follow
and we're just happy to be along for the
ride thank you
thank you michelle it sounds amazing
we're all going to be
cheering thursday morning but in the
meantime we do have some media joining
us
and we do have a question from leo
enright from irish television
please go ahead leo
do we have leo hello
hello
we're not able to hear leo right at the
moment but we also do have some social
media questions
that we have um received today and so
let's throw one out there
from michelle at johnson from darla
jackson
from facebook will perseverance start
building a base camp for future
explorers
that is a great question um so
perseverance is a is a
it's a pretty big robot but it's not
quite big enough uh to be building the
base camp
uh perseverance is one of uh several
robotic missions that we've got on the
horizon now
um we think of these missions these
robotic missions
as more more like scouts um
they they sort of help us uh learn about
the new environment
uh figure out if that's where we would
like to build a base camp
um so yeah perseverances
they won't be building the base camp for
us but it might be very instrumental in
helping us decide
if we if we want to build a base count
whether this is an area that we might
want to consider
all right let's try our media question
again leo enright of irish television
can you hear us sir yes i hope you're
hearing me this time
yes sir we can please go ahead i i have
a helicopter question
i i was wondering what's the experience
like going to be for us back here on
earth
in that first wright brothers moment
are we going to see this helicopter
taking off
with cameras from the main rover
are we going to have a live
commentary uh or is this going to be a
much more low-key event
mimi all right i'll take that all right
tim
well thank you for the question uh leo
it's it's a good question
uh the operation of the helicopter it is
done remotely
right so the long answer here uh we send
up the commands prepare them a few days
ahead of time
send them up and then the helicopter
operates autonomously right at a given
time it'll take off
fly you know take a few images come back
and land
okay and then we will have some images
that we send back the first day
after the flight and landing and then
over the next two days
we'll be sending more data related to
the flight
so that's the data from the helicopter
and they'll be primarily how did the
helicopter perform
you know what were the onboard voltages
currents and
what were the vehicle state as it was
flying how well did it follow the
trajectory
and also we have as icing on the cake a
few pictures uh
colored pictures that we will take again
that's for additional function
so from the helicopter centric we'll
start getting data back
a few hours on the first afterwards on
the first day and then the next two day
we'll be getting streams of data
on the perseverance rover side the
person knowing that where we have
commanded the helicopter
to fly you know the waypoints that we've
given perseverance rover will be
pointing their cameras
also along the path trajectory to take
images
and we'll be sending data back so it
won't be instantaneously within minutes
but within the same day we'll start to
see both visual
and i'm very biased towards the
engineering data the engineering
telemetry on how well the
uh the flight went and then over the
next couple days
we'll get more and more information
thank you mimi you're allowed to be
biased the ingenuity experiment is
extraordinary
so our next media question is jake
robbins
and he must have been preparing for this
day because he's calling from we
marshall podcast go ahead jake
all right thank you yeah uh there's
questions for uh from michael about the
moxie instrument
uh assuming everything goes real well
with this and it's turning out
oxygen like crazy um how scalable is it
is it as simple as just making one you
know 100 times the size or are there
new technical challenges that will come
after that in making it bigger
a great question and i'm really pleased
to
report that it's a question we're making
a lot of progress on
there's a development going on right now
in the laboratory
testing out um these electrolysis
systems this sox
system that produces uh you know 100
times
more um oxygen than what our little one
does and there's a separate
project going on developing a full-size
compressor it scales extremely
well um and that said that does not mean
the
full-scale system is 100 times heavier
or 100 times bigger
we expect a full-scale system that can
produce
two to three kilograms an hour to be
about a cubic meter
and to weigh about a metric ton about a
thousand kilograms
of course we will learn a lot from this
mission that what may cause us to
redesign
we have to remember that the full-scale
system will not only have to put out
more oxygen
but do it for a solid year so
that implies changes in things like dust
filtering
technology so it's well underway it's
basically
retaining the same design principles and
methods
thank you michael our next media
question comes from haneka
wietering of ace media haneka
can you hear us hi this is hannah
please go ahead the question is for
mimi and perhaps anyone else who would
like to answer it
mars and in what ways can rotate be
useful for future
okay mimi did you hear that
uh i didn't hear the whole question
what's the question in what ways will
helicopters be
used in the future was that the question
uh i vote for human missions in addition
to the robotic mission
sorry tammy can you translate uh most of
the questions will you please repeat the
question please
in what ways can rotorcraft be useful
for
future
i'm sorry haneka we're having trouble
hearing you maybe we'll try to get you
back on a better line
in the meantime let's go to some more
social media questions
this is for jeff
is nasa preparing 3d printers that will
utilize
martian soil or material we send
so that we can build storage and living
quarters in the foreseeable future do we
have any plans jeff
to go building we do actually
um space technology mission directorate
and others have been investing
in 3d printing technology
we've actually flown devices to the
space station so we can test it out in
microgravity
we've been able to produce small
implements with those devices at
on the iss we started out printing with
plastics
progressed to metals a lot of liquid
rocket engine parts are being printed
with
additive manufacture